[Music]
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor but
with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward
nerdy kid
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish he'd get into some trouble
there's still time
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke
and my grandfather left us this creepy
old farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing well i
wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason are you
troubled by strange noises in the middle
of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
you guys hear that something's coming
all city took the walking dead
we're closed
[Music]
you